بات الامر بالنسبه لنعمه بمثابه جوله
يوميه بحثا عن حليب لطفلها جاد
مهمه ليست يسيره فرفع الدعم الحكومي عن
اسعار الحليب لم ينهي ازمه ندرته في
الاصوات
[موسيقى]
صارت كتير قويه ومين قادر يتحمل هالقد
قرار وزاره الصحه برفع الدعم كليا عن
استيراد حليب الاطفال يمس الاف العائلات
دعم كان يقتصر على 50% من اسعار حليب
الاطفال دون عمر السنه وعليه تضاعف سعر
الحليب لكن الوزاره تعز رفع الدعم الى شح
الاموال ولتهريب كميات من الحليب المدعوم
الى سوريا او تخزينها من قبل بعض التجار
لبيعها باسعار اعلى ما تسبب في فقدان
الحليب من الاسواق تم شيل الدعم تدريجيا
وهي سياسه الدعم يلي ادت لها فقدان المنتج
بالسوق وتخزين وتهريبه فكان من الضروره ان
ينشال الدعم كرمال انه الحليب بينوجد
للامهات يلي عندها اطفال خاصه بين السفر
وست اشهر خاصه النساء يلي ما عم بترضع
وعلت اصوات عده تنتقد قرار وز الصحه كونه
يعكس ما يسميه متابعون عشوائيه الجهات
الرسميه في التعامل مع الازمات المعيشيه
صار المطلوب انه ينعمل مقاربه شامله
بتتناول مختلف الجوانب وبتغطي يعني
القطاعات المختلفه يعني نحن عم نحكي على
حاجه الى الامن الغذائي عم نحكي الى حاجه
الى امن الطاقه نحن عم نحكي على الوصول
الى الاحتياجات الاساسيه من دواء ويشكل
رفع الدعم عن الحليب احد اوجه الازمات
المتعدده التي يواجهها اللبنانيون منذ
سنوات وتنعكس تداعياتها على امنهم الصحي
والغذائي والاجتماعي
يزيد رفع الدعم الحكومي عن حليب الاطفال
من ثقل تداعيات الانهيار الاقتصادي على
اللبنانيين تداعيات تتطلب خططا رسميه لنجم
الانهيار لاسيما وان 80% من اللبنانيين
باتوا من الفقراء وفق المنظمات الدوليه
جونيطونيوس الجزيره بيروت